all right Happy New Year everybody this
is gonna be my best of 2017 video for
TVs and movies so bust out your claws
let's do it hopefully you all made it
through 2017 with at least a couple
things that you were really really happy
with there was a lot of garbage during
2017 but there were also a lot of really
bright spots to the way I cut this was
montage style but the numbering system
doesn't necessarily indicate the one was
better for me than another with the
exception of my number one pick that's
still like the best thing that I think
happened this year but for the most part
these are just like the ten real big
bright spots from TV and movies I don't
think a spoiler warning is necessary
this late in the year but just in case
you didn't watch any movies and didn't
watch any TV spoiler warning for what
happened during 2017 Supergirl Landing
you gonna do a superhero landing wait
for it
[Music]
and maximum estimate Vietnamese
you must be Peter well those movies will
all take place in the world that we are
now creating for for you know for Peter
Parker I mean it'll they'll be adjunct
to it they may be different locations
but it will still all be in the same
world and they will be connected to each
other as well
[Music]
I had such a build-up a Wonder Woman and
I was so ready like I had these months
and months and months of me getting
super excited about this character I
literally just wanted to attack to give
it a bite to dive in tell Susie I wanted
to know it was me
[Music]
now is the time for action
don't be
that was pretty heavy but I think we can
all probably agree that Logan is one of
if not the best comic book film of all
time now like new water market is set
but a lot of these are meant to be funny
moments a lot of them are serious drama
but just the bright spots that I found
during the year I'm sure everybody has a
slightly different top 10 list but
Marvel getting the x-men back or
potentially getting them back is such a
huge deal
they've been raked over the coals so
much I think just the opportunity to see
a Marvel quality version of an x-men
movie is just so exciting Kevin Feige
reacting to Amy Pascal which is this
sweet icing on the cake that was
spider-man coming back to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe just from an
organizational standpoint the idea of
crisis on Earth X a four-hour TV movie
involving all these characters is
amazing that they were even able to
attempt something like this there were a
couple things about it that bothered
mean it of course is you to expect
trying to blend the tones of four very
different TV shows and four very
different writing staffs there were
plenty of logic problems but just the
scope of what they were able to attempt
and pull off is so much better than what
their competitors have come up with at
least on television the best comparison
that you could make is that Kevin Feige
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is as
organized as DC TV in their universe
that's where it falls apart a little bit
so let's not conflate Marvel Cinematic
Universe goings-on with DC TV goings-on
cannot say enough about patty Jenkins
hopefully she sticks around for a long
time in the DC Universe so that she
could do a Man of Steel movie herself
because she just gets that character if
you listen to her Wonder Woman
commentary most of the movie in the
character was inspired by a Richard
Donner Superman infinity war is such a
big deal even though it's not coming out
till next year the trailer itself made
my list it's the 10th anniversary of
Marvel Studios the culmination of 10
years of careful planning by Kevin Feige
I think we're all expecting it to blow
our minds but I will do a 2018 video for
most anticipated things later this week
so don't worry there's still so much
other big stuff coming
speaking of culmination even though
there's all the Star Wars stuff that's
going on in the live-action universe we
finally got the culmination of obi-wan
Darth Maul going all the way back to
Phantom Menace
no surprise there are a couple Game of
Thrones moments on the list I would have
put more on here but I wanted to keep
this a top 10 and I didn't want Game of
Thrones to monopolize the list so feel
the fire and tell Cersei it was me Jon
Snow meeting the dragons also a seismic
shift in the payoffs of the show in
Szechuan debacle aside one of the best
episodes of television this year was
Rick and Morty the Rick Lantis mix-up
with a story that only a show like Rick
and Morty could pull off and then
obviously my number one probably the one
that matters the most is Logan just the
entire movie this is something that they
could only have done after Hugh
Jackman's long career you couldn't do
this with any of the other characters
Robert Downey jr. with the Iron Man
character is the next best example but
he's been playing that character for
half of the amount of time that Hugh
Jackman played The Wolverine character
so just the way the Wolverine character
works the way they incorporated the idea
of his longevity into the story how it
transcended the idea of what you think a
comic book movie is capable of like it
just said a new bar for quality one of
Patrick Stewart's best performances from
his entire life not just of the Xavier
character same thing for Hugh Jackman
same thing for the Laura character and I
really hope that this Marvel disney deal
doesn't kill the chances of us getting
another movie with that character
whatever they do with the timeline
however they decide to explain that
because it's gonna get messy no matter
what well let me know in the comments
what was your favorite thing from movies
or TV during 2017 what'll happen next is
I have new Game of Thrones but like I
said I'll do my 2018 most anticipated
video next week there'll be some more
Marvel and DC stuff coming up and I
still have that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway that's going on so just be sure
to subscribe to get everything click
here for that new infinity war video and
click here to learn about what's coming
up on Titans this season thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you